der astronaut reinhold ewald also
spannend bei phoenix schönen abend dort
tschüss
[Musik]
das sind bilder aus florida und das was
wir dort sehen das ist die falcon 9
trägerrakete mit der zwei astronauten ja
um 22 und 33 zumindest ist es so geplant
zur iss starten werden und das alles ja
das kommt von allen masc der ist bei uns
eher bekannt als chef von tesla
aber er ist auch chef von spacex und das
ist die firma die für ja die nasa jetzt
eigentlich die flüge durchführte schönen
guten abend meine damen und herren wir
sind sehr gespannt
wir sind sehr gespannt deswegen weil es
dann doch mal wieder notwendig ist ein
begriff zu zitieren nämlich den
historischen augenblick den wir erleben
werden
nach so vielen jahren in denen die usa
nicht haben starten können mit eigenen
raketen wollen sie das heute wieder
probieren um 20 33 bei nicht ganz so
gutem wetter wie wir sehen und der
präsident ist auch gleich mal angereist
um sich das anzuschauen er landete
gerade mit der air force one
das sind bilder von der landung etwas
ungewöhnlich dass die präsident oder
dass der präsident so knapp vor dem
start kommt er hatte wahrscheinlich noch
sehr viele wichtige dinge zu tun und er
hat angekündigt
er hatte angekündigt dass er auf jeden
fall sich diesen start ansehen möchte
das hat auch was mit plastisch zu tun
auch mit der situation in den usa
insgesamt das wird nach vielen jahren
nachdem man auf die russische sojus
zurückgreifen musste ganz wichtig sagen
zu dokumentieren
wir sind wieder da wir können selber zur
iss starten
ja und robert bänken und das hurley die
schon in der kapsel sitzen von der
falken 9
die sind jetzt ziemlich gespannt weil
astronauten
auch ein bisschen nervös sein dürfen das
kann ich gleich mit reinhold ewald
besprechen professor reinhold ewald ist
physiker und astronaut ist selber im
weltraum gewesen mit der mir 1997
begrüße sie sehr herzlich schönen guten
abend wir werden gleich den staaten
miteinander besprechen professor werner
ist bei mir generaldirektor der eso aus
paris ganz schönen abend wünsche ich wir
sind sehr gespannt weil naja bei der
start situation ist das wetter immer
noch sehr entscheidend und wir sehen
dass selbst der präsident hier mit einem
regenschirm runter geht
es soll sehr heftig regnen in florida
und das ist eigentlich nicht so wirklich
gut noch schlimmer ist es wenn es auch
noch blitze die startchancen die haben
sich im laufe des tages heute verändert
zu anfang sei es nicht so schlecht aus
jetzt ist es ein bisschen schwieriger
wir sind sehr gespannt ob das
funktionieren wird auf jeden fall sind
wir gespannt auf 22 uhr 33 das kann auch
um 22.29 noch abgebrochen werden
das haben wir bei der shuttle-mission
immer mal wieder erlebt auch die letzte
nacht mission des shuttle der letzte
nachtstart wurde fünf minuten vor dem
start abgebrochen deswegen das ist schon
sehr spannend was wir heute abend
erleben
und wir erleben ganz sicher und das
werden wir gleich besprechen hier im
studio
ja wir erleben ein bisschen einen
historischen augenblick denn das ist
jetzt eine ganz neue mission die die
amerikaner vor einige eben auch eine
neue mission die allen masc in den
himmel und zu als es bringen will er ist
und da ganz schönen druck dass das heute
funktioniert ein kleiner überblick über
diesen tag
nach zwei wochen quarantäne geht es für
sie heute ab ins all blicken und doug
hurley werden die ersten amerikanischen
astronauten seien die nach einstellung
des space shuttle programms der nasa von
den usa zur internationalen raumstation
starten
pioniere sind die bereits weltraum
erfahrenen männer weil sie als erster
astronauten in einer raumkapsel
unterwegs sein werden die ein privates
unternehmen entwickelt hat spacex heißt
die firma des paypal und tesla gründer
elon musk nachdem die stolze
raumfahrtnation usa jahrelang auf
russische sojus-raketen angewiesen war
hofft sie nun auf einen erfolgreichen
testflug denn die amerikaner haben
hochfliegender ambitionen im al baker
für die astronauten werden beweisen dass
diese partnerschaft zwischen einem
privaten unternehmen und einer
weltraumbehörde erfolgreich sein kann
kosten zu senken und mithilfe
wiederverwertbarer raketen
wirtschaftlich nachhaltig zum mond zu
fliegen und irgendwann zum mars in der
computersimulation ist er schon gelungen
der bilderbuch start ins all
die falcon 9 rakete soll um 22 uhr 33
deutscher zeit vom weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral zur iss abheben wenn das
wetter mitspielt und die mission gelingt
wäre spacex seinem eigentlichen ziel
deutlich näher der kommerziellen
raumfahrt ja auch aus diesem grunde ist
es sehr spannend
sie können in dem kleinen fenster sehen
wie die situation vor ort im augenblick
ist professor wörner
ich habe eben gesagt das ist so ein
augenblick wir sind ja an journalisten
immer gerne dabei mit den historischen
augenblick ist es für sie eine
historische augen na ja es ist schon
etwas besonderes aber für mich sind
eigentlich bei jeder staat von
astronauten immer etwas besonderes
ich war nun bei vielen dabei
shuttle-starts ich war dabei bei sojus
starts und immer muss ich sagen war ich
auch gleichzeitig sehr ja wie sollte ich
schon sagen aufgeregt reicht mir nicht
ich war gespannt das gilt schon seit
meiner kindheit in der ich die apollo
und gemini flüge verfolgt habe es ist
halt wirklich eine konnten
organisierte und kontrollierte
explosionen die da abläuft das muss man
sich immer klar machen wir so eine
rakete ins all fliegt und da ist bei mir
schon auch nervosität zu spüren und hier
natürlich jetzt auch eine rakete die so
noch nicht geflogen ist mit astronauten
da ist natürlich die spannung noch mal
besonders hoch und ich habe eben das
wetter erwähnt bei dem space shuttle war
es ja tatsächlich ganz oft so dass
dieses besondere wetter in florida diese
wetterküche wie die das da unten nennen
weil wieder ein bisschen verrückt
gespielt hatte gab es große türme
gewitter und so weiter und manchmal war
tatsächlich der stadt ganz kurz vor dem
start abgesagt worden
wie sieht das jetzt bei der falken aus
das ist prinzipiell bei raketen sowie
wie ich ja sage es ist eine
kontrollierte explosion und da kann ich
mir natürlich einen blitzeinschlag
zwischendurch mal nicht gut erlauben das
heißt auch die ganze elektronik systeme
an bord sind natürlich gefährdet also
das ist schon hoch technik im auf dem
engsten raum und deshalb ist klar dass
man ein gewisses gutes wird da brauchen
wir haben zum beispiel in
französisch-guyana auch immer noch die
situation ob wir winde haben in der
höheren höhe quer scheer winde
so dass wir dann womöglich beachten
müssen dass teile herunterfallen die
bevölkerung treffen könnten das ist auch
noch ein zusätzliches risiko also es
gibt da schon einige wetterrisiken von
blitz und donner über starken regen und
bis hin zu extremem winden
dort wo die europäische institution
die raketen starten lässt in guyana ist
ja ein ähnliches klima wie hier
warum startet man eigentlich in
subtropischen klima das du eigentlich
unpraktisch da gibt es immer wieder
gewitter und dann muss doch so ein start
wieder verschoben wäre also das
subtropische haben uns nicht ausgesucht
wir sind ganz froh dass für ein
französisch guyana keine erdbeben haben
das ist schon mal gut aber es ist ganz
einfach ein effekt wie wir wissen dreht
sich die erde pro tag einmal um ihre
achse das heißt sie schafft in 24
stunden 40.000 kilometer das ist eine
ordentliche geschwindigkeit und wenn man
jetzt in einem flug will sozusagen in
äquator ebene dann nimmt man diese
geschwindigkeit gerne mit das heißt die
sojus von französisch-guyana ist viel
leistungsfähiger als zum beispiel die
sojus vom balkon uhr
es gibt ganz praktische gründe von dort
aus zu starten und das heißt
leistungsfähiger heißt man kann auch
mehr hochbringen ja weil einfach die
sozusagen die drehung ein bisschen mehr
schwung für die ferien bringt mir mit
und das zweite ist wenn man in
irgendeine andere bahn will von der
äquator bahn können sie jeden beliebigen
winkel auf der erde ansteuern werden
wenn sie schon mal in 50 grad nord sind
dann kommen sie nicht mehr auf den
äquator ohne besonders viel kraftstoff
radelt ebert wir sehen die astronauten
in der kapsel
was ist denn das für ein gefühl wenn man
da drin sitzt abgesehen davon dass es
normalerweise vor allen dingen bei den
russischen sojus verdammt eng ist und
das ist eben auch wieder der effekt das
nun zu einer kapsel zurückgekehrt ist
dass man von diesem voluminöseren
shuttle was ja gleichzeitig transport
gefährt und mannschafts abteil
beinhaltet dass man da wieder auf die
kapseln zurückgekommen ist das ist kein
rückschritt in musste ich ein
rückschritt sein wenn man tatsächlich
mit dieser kapsel nur eins erreichen
würden nämlich drei menschen oder in dem
fall jetzt hier vier menschen sicher zu
einer raumstation zu bringen das ist
natürlich unmöglich wenn man sich auf
längere reisen zum mars oder sowas
beginnen aber die kapsel hat eben den
vorteil
sie sitzt außerhalb der gefahr sie sitzt
oben auf der rakete
damit ist der weg der fluchtweg nach
oben offen und vor allen dingen kann
nichts wie beim shuttle bitter erfahren
nichts drauf fallen
das heißt es gibt auch für die letzten
sozusagen sekunden vorher aber auch für
den start noch notsysteme es ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt werden dieses
notsysteme scharf geschaltet
die sind in diese kapsel die wir gleich
noch wahrscheinlich mehr sehen werden
ein integriert das heißt diese das sind
ja dass wir haben eben gesagt das ist
eine kontrollierte explosion da ist es
nur um kontrollierte explosion
das ist einfach treibstoff der wenn er
mit dem oxidation zusammengebracht wird
gewaltige kräfte entwickelt da reden wir
dann auch davon fünffacher neunfachen
erdbeschleunigung in abschnitten diese
dieser flucht von der explodierenden
rakete und das musste die firma spacex
jahr nachweisen dass musste sie erst mal
in tests auch nachweisen dass diese
sonder raketen die an der kapsel
angebracht sind
diesen diese flucht bewerkstelligen wie
ist die situation wenn sie da drin
sitzen und ja quasi isoliert sind von
allem anderen
sie müssen sich konzentrieren und das
ist wahrscheinlich gut dass man ein
gewisses ja prozedere da hat aber
trotzdem ist das eine besondere
isolation ja gerade momentan also
während wir reden sind ja die beiden
astronauten in ihren sitzen angeschnallt
die luke ist zu und es passiert dass man
gar nichts mehr also die die drucke
checks sind vor vorgenommen und bis zum
start ist jetzt eigentlich nur warten
dass die faktoren mitspielen dass die
kapsel keine fehlfunktion hat das tanken
klappt das wird auch noch jetzt
anberaumt und dass auch das wetter
mitspielt ist uns hat man musik
eingespielt und einfach ein heimisches
gefühl dann zu erzeugen
es soll kollegen kolleginnen gegeben
haben die eingeschlafen sind ist aber
glaube ich mir ins reich der fabel zu ja
wir haben gerade jetzt in der korona
krise natürlich immer mal wieder gehört
wie sieht das eigentlich aus wenn an
astronaut mal darüber erzählt wie er
isoliert ist und wie geht er mit dieser
isolation um es gibt ja nun viele
astronauten auf der iss schon auch ein
halbes jahr zugebracht haben da gibt es
dann auch kollegen oder kolleginnen die
dabei sind aber immerhin ist das eine
isolation situation
alexander gerst hat auch darüber
berichtet rund 400 kilometer von einem
normalen büro schreibtisch entfernt
arbeitete der deutsche astronaut
alexander gerst 2018 ein halbes jahr
lang war auf der raumstation iss im
einsatz weit weg von familie und
freunden gegen die einsamkeit hilft vor
allem mentale vorbereitung soziale
kontakte dank internet kein problem im
gegenteil die viel größere
herausforderung die anhaltende präsenz
von partnern und mitbewohnern in engem
raum dann gibt es konfliktpotenzial wenn
man da von anfang an ein klima der
kommunikation aufbau der toleranz das
leben und leben lassen dass man schnell
mit seinem kameraden apparaten redet
wenn irgendein problem auch für dann
kann man die eigentlich relativ schnell
lösen
die ungewohnte lage ist nicht nur last
sondern auch eine chance damit man wegen
auch das negative schossen daneben auch
die möglichkeiten sich anschaut die ja
zum beispiel wie sie dass man jede menge
private projekte die man wochen und
monaten schon mal meter kopf hat endlich
mal fertig bringt dann mentale kraft
disziplin und vor allem toleranz werden
den zusammenhalt stärken und helfen die
korona krise zu überwinden
diese tipps sagt gerst funktionieren im
weltall wie auf der erde gleichermaßen
gut
[Musik]
professor wir haben das so ein bisschen
spielerisch jetzt gehört von alexander
gerst hat das ja auch immer sehr gut
kommunizieren kann wie er damit umgeht
aber im ernst ist es manchmal nicht so
dass die astronauten da oben und sie
haben ja zum beispiel auch astronauten
quasi geführt gekuscht vom boden aus
dass die manchmal wirklich einen rappel
kriegen oder sind die so diszipliniert
nein das ist eigentlich ein effekt auch
der auswahl und das trainings dass man
da die eigentliche aufgabe so hochwertig
dass man sich zusammenreißen dass man ja
auch weiß ich bin oben so und so lange
jetzt beschäftigt und wenn dann die zeit
der brücke kommt dann macht es auch sinn
zurückzukommen um auch all die
ergebnisse und auch den eigenen körper
wieder medizinischen experimenten am
boden zu gehen zumal das war jedenfalls
bei mir der vorherrschende gedanke ich
wäre gern noch länger geblieben aber
irgendwann ist dann die mission als
solche eben auch wichtig und das bringt
die leute zusammen das klappt über die
kulturen hinweg das ist ja das
erstaunlich das klappt auch über die
verschiedenen beruflichen wege hinweg
wir haben hier zwei piloten aber da oben
treffen sie auf wissenschaftler oder
mediziner
das sind also ganz verschiedene
erfahrungsbereich die da zusammen
funktionieren müssen das training hat es
wirklich geschafft diese
erfahrungsbereich dann auch zusammen zu
bringen wir sehen jetzt die bilder aus
cape canaveral oben die kapsel die oben
drauf sitzt die nervös ist man nicht
wenn man sind im pulsschlag gemessen
hätte ich glaube nicht dass meine
mannschaften die ich sehr nervös gewesen
wären das ist wie in der simulation man
wird wirklich 10 x 15 x in diese
situation gebracht schließt die lücke
vergiss die die trainings welt drum
herum die einen fehler einspielen und
versucht nur mit dieser aufgabe gerecht
zu werden und gerade bei den beiden mit
der erfahrung schon von raumflügen beide
sind ja schon zweimal im all gewesen ist
das wahrscheinlich jetzt der vorher
schon der gedanke nur keinen falschen
schalter umlegen nur nichts falsch
machen bei mir rutschte ein gurt aus der
verankerung beim probedurchlauf das
wollte ich bestimmt am start nicht noch
mal erleben also diese konzentration
herrscht ruhe so wir sehen da die kapsel
und ja wir fliegen also oder besser
gesagt nicht wir aber die beiden
astronauten fliegen zur iss professor
werner das ist ein internationales
begegnungszentrum geworden da kommen
ganz viele nationen zusammen und das ist
ja auch gut so vor allen dingen wissen
wir ja nach 1990 wie ich das wichtig das
war für die zusammenarbeit auch zwischen
russen und amerikanern
warum ist man da eigentlich oben auf der
iss wir sehen immer bilder davon wir
sehen die astronauten schweben da oben
freuen sich über neue besucher aber was
machen die dann doch ja also die
internationale raumstation hat viele
viele facetten
sie ist entstanden tatsächlich aus der
überlegung der zusammenarbeit zwischen
ost und west und das ist auch heute noch
ein ganz wichtiger punkt die
geopolitische wirkung dieser ss
überirdische krisen hinweg denken sie an
die krim krise oder andere dinge es hat
immer funktioniert immer weiter
funktioniert also diese geopolitische
wirkung sollten wir nicht
vernachlässigen und wenn die astronauten
dann berichten dass sie da
zusammenarbeiten über alle grenzen
hinweg finde ich das schon mal ein
wichtiger punkt aber die er es es ist
nicht mehr da oben nur allein aus
geopolitischen gründen sondern auch als
forschungs gründen auf der iss werden
ganz viele forschungen betrieben am
menschen medizin forschung über
knochenschwund über die frage des
immunsystems über blutdruck über
salzhaushalt über alle möglichen fragen
der alterung also die ergebnisse von
dort nutzen auch direkt auf der erde und
es gibt natürlich auch versuche zu
materialwissenschaften und es gibt
grundlagen versuche also wir machen ja
derzeit gerade auf der internetseite
raumstation wird auch geschaut nach
antimaterie dann ist das eine der großen
rätseln
wie ist das wie es der urknall gewesen
und normalerweise müsste genauso viel
materie wie antimaterie dasein gesehen
aber nur sehr viel materie nicht anti
materie also sind auch grundlagen
versuche die auf der iss durchgeführt
werden also die ice es ist eine
begegnungsstätte ja sie ist ein
brückenbauer überirdische grenzen ja und
sie ist vor allen dingen auch ein
ausgezeichnetes labor
ja und da wollen wir mal hinschauen auf
die iss und ihre funktion über 100
milliarden dollar kostet die iss bisher
aber lohnen sich die experimente
überhaupt und vor allem muss dass ein
astronaut machen oder könnten das auch
maschinen man kann viele der experimente
und der studien die man dadurch führt
natürlich auch mit nicht benannten
satelliten durchführen
ich habe das immer angezweifelt ob wir
unbedingt menschen im weltall benötigen
um diese forschung da durchzuführen
sowie beim projekt ikarus zwei
astronauten montieren hochriskant eine
antenne außen an der iss
damit können tiere mit gps-sendern ihre
daten ins all schicken
die hauptidee ist wirklich das
zusammenspiel der tiere zu verstehen
also die tiere als intelligente sensoren
des lebens auf der erde zu haben wenn
wir genau hinschauen dann kann uns jeder
art was anderes sagen und was ganz
besonderes sorgen hätten zb auch nie
gedacht dass ziegen am etwa uns sagen
können wann der vulkan ausbricht
tiere die vor erdbeben oder
vulkanausbrüche warnen
eigentlich ein sinnvolles projekt aber
ich frage mich warum brauchen wir dazu
astronauten im weltall warum ist den
astronauten einen riskanten
außenbordeinsatz machen um dieses modul
an die raumstation anzuschrauben warum
können wir das nicht mit unbemannten
satelliten machen aber die
weltraumforschung hat auch schon
konkrete nutzen das sogenannte kalte
plasma zum beispiel es macht chronische
wunden keimfrei tötet bakterien ab
zufällig im weltall entdeckt stiftet es
jetzt großen nutzen in der medizin
oder die forschung zu osteoporose eine
krankheit bei der knochen an festigkeit
verlieren
auch beim aufenthalt im all schwinden
muskeln und knochenmasse gerst radelt
und rennt dagegen an der sport im all
bringt vielleicht erkenntnisse zur
osteoporose die iss seit 18 jahren ein
fliegendes labor mit über 2.000
experimenten aus den naturwissenschaften
das größte technologieprojekt aller
zeiten deutschland kostet das 180
millionen euro im jahr haben wir
eigentlich immer wieder auch in
verschiedenen studien nachgewiesen dass
der der nutzen eigentlich eher ein
nutzen ist der nicht im
wissenschaftlichen oder im ökonomischen
bereich ist und der nutzen ist er im
bereich der völkerverständigung für die
wissenschaft gibt es andere wege auch
durchaus kostengünstige wege diese
experimente und diese forschungen
durchzuführen amerikaner und russen
arbeiten hand in hand
die iss mit typen wie gerst eine
inspiration für den nachwuchs vielleicht
darf man da nicht nach dem preis fragen
sind im grunde sofort angesprochen
worden
wir haben ja die information dass das ja
letztlich steuergelder sind und die
informationen das ist aber für uns
bürger in europa doch sehr wichtig seien
einige beispiele aus der medizin gesehen
aus spaß macht man das ja da nicht und
selbst wenn man es aus spaß machen würde
wir fahren in urlaub und wir machen das
aus spaß und offensichtlich machen was
immer weiter auch in zeiten von corona
diskutieren wir jetzt wann dürfen wir
endlich wieder wegfahren und laden uns
nicht nur einfach vom internet die
bilder von von mallorca und das könnten
wir auch mal wäre ja genauso schön zu
hause im sessel sitzen und mallorca
feeling ein bierchen und das war's dann
machen wir nicht die menschen wollen
nach draußen dass erstmals ein punkt
aber es lohnt sich wirklich die die
astronauten raum verdient sich wir haben
in der esa eine genaue analyse
durchgeführt wie ist das mit den
investierten mitteln und dem rückfluss
wir sind im mittel dazu gekommen dass
ein euro investiert in die raumfahrt
bringt sechs euro zurück indirekten
investitionen in der wirtschaft und den
anderen bereichen und für die
astronauten
die immer gern so als überflüssig
bezeichnet wird ist das verhältnis immer
noch eins zu zwei als 1 euro investiert
2 euro rückfluss und wir können nun mal
einfach nicht bei robotern blutdruck
messen oder auf jeden fall wäre das
unsinn oder die frage stellen hat er
jetzt osteoporose oder was ist mit dem
immunsystem also allein die
medizinforschung würde es schon
rechtfertigen aus meiner sicht die
raumfahrt mitmenschen auch durchzuführen
aber es ist noch etwas anders wenn
menschen in der im all waren oder sind
und sie uns berichten dann ist das was
anderes als wenn wir nur bilder von
einer kamera bekommen die kommentare die
kommentare von astronauten über die
schönheit unserer erde über die
verletzlichkeit unserer erde und das
untermalt mit bildern jedenfalls nicht
rührt das und ich glaube es rührt viele
und außerdem ist noch einen effekt jeder
astronaut weckt uns ja auch so ein
bisschen bei uns faszination inspiration
und wir sagen der hatte einen traum und
hat den traum umgesetzt und wenn wir das
alle sagen wir wollen in zukunft auch
träume umsetzen dann ist mir nicht mehr
bange um die zukunft von europa und der
welt wir sehen bilder jetzt nochmal aus
der kapsel
und das ist sicherlich jetzt auch ein
bisschen mehr platz als bei der jesus
sehe ich das richtig
nominell nicht wir reden über zehn
kubikmeter weil das so wie es war es
aufgeteilt 3,5 kubikmeter
wenn ich das erwähnen dann sage ich das
ist eine telefonzelle und das publikum
meistens jetzt schon unter 20 oder was
guckt mich unglaublich an was denn bitte
eine telefonzelle ist also das ist sehr
eng und man muss schon gut befreundet
sein um mit diesen zwei kollegen
kolleginnen da sich einzupassen oben ist
ein bisschen mehr platz hier ist das in
einem raum aber auf meine nachfragen
auch die sitze können nicht weggeklappt
werden das heißt man hat also nicht den
ganzen raum zum schweben sondern man
wird in dieser sitzposition mehr oder
weniger dem flug dann auch durchstehen
müssen es ist stauraum da aber es ist
nicht wirklich aber sie fliegen zwei
tage zur sojus das ist ja zwei tage
quasi gefesselt in einer doch sehr
eigentlich unbequemen situation
abgesehen davon dass man nicht
klaustrophobisch sein da haben die
langen frage wie man das touristisch
verkaufen kann
ein solcher flug wer hat noch nicht mal
eine heizung also das war wirklich
überleben bis man in der station
ankommen die station ist das genaue
gegenteil das ist ein jumbo jetzt
wirklich auch an volumen und hier ist es
so dass die diese astronauten sehr viel
schneller jetzt zur raumstation kommen
also das schnellste war bis jetzt sechs
stunden ein sojus flug
da hilft natürlich die raumstation
kräftig mit als relaisstation für
videobilder und ähnliches hier ist mit
patíz unterwegs dann die das doping
morgen zu erwarten
also die bilder weiterhin hier aus der
kapsel
und ja mit auch neuer kleidung aber da
kommen wir vielleicht später noch mal
dazu das sind nicht mehr die orangenen
anzüge die sie bisher an hatten etwa
beim space hat trotzdem noch mal zurück
auf die sagen wir mal auch deutsche
beteiligung wir haben ja mit dem
columbus modul auch ein laboratorium im
all haben sie immer gesagt also etwas wo
wir unter ganz anderen bedingungen
testen und ausprobieren können ja das
columbus modul ist ja ein europäisches
modell was im endausbau in deutschland
gefertigt wurde die hülle ist aus
italien geliefert worden als ein
typisches europäisches projekt und daran
sind viele europäische experimente
untergebracht und diese experimente
werden nicht nur von den europäern
genutzt sondern auch von den russen den
amerikanern denen jetzt ein eigenes
modul von den japaner ja ja aber wenn
man das da ist eben wirklich da ist sind
keine grenzen mit visazwang und solchen
dingen die wir auf der erde so
unglaublich lieben jedenfalls ich finde
sie überflüssig also auf der
internationalen station gibt es das
alles nicht und man schwebt von hier
nach da von japan auch kurz zur
russischen seite dann zur amerikanischen
land zur europäischen und ohne
passkontrolle und visa kontrolle und das
macht natürlich auch etwas aus und dass
das wenn man das richtig erfährt und
hört dann hat man so ein bisschen die
vorstellung was leicht auf der erde auch
einfach mal hinkriegen könnten das wäre
zu hoffen
nun ist ja der deutsche anteil ein doch
sehr großer mit den franzosen zusammen
es gibt ja auch mal pläne was alleine
als deutsche zu machen so einen
deutschen weltraumbahnhof kann man sich
sowas auch vorstellen also dann sollten
sie vielleicht jemand vom dlr fragen
aber nicht den chef der europäischen
raumfahrt-agentur der steht immer auf
mit beiden beinen in europa auf der
europäischen seite
trotzdem haben wir einen beitrag dazu
was es mit diesem plan auf sich hat was
hier dampft und gleich feuer speit ist
keine mittelalterliche kanone sondern
raumfahrttechnik von morgen
die ingenieure und techniker des
start-up-unternehmens hey impuls
entwickeln in der schwäbischen provinz
einen mini launcher eine kleine rakete
aus carbonfasern die in zukunft mini
satelliten in eine erdumlaufbahn bringen
soll
besonders originell der brennstoff die
neue technologie für den antrieb besteht
daraus dass wir kerzenwachs wie ich hier
und blog habt als als brennstoff
verwenden in unseren triebwerken und
dadurch ein sehr sicheres
antriebskonzept haben wie bei einer
kerze die man anzündet braucht man eben
auch noch sauerstoff damit dieses
wachstum brennt wir verwenden flüssigen
sauerstoff und brennen damit diese wachs
plätze ab mit ihrem innovativen antrieb
wollen sie satelliten mit einem
maximalgewicht von bis zu 500 kilogramm
ins all schießen
ein riesenmarkt der zukunft für den man
auch entsprechende startplätze braucht
ob französisch guyana oder cape
canaveral weltraum bahnhöfe dieser
größenordnung sind für mini launcher und
mini satelliten allerdings zu groß zu
teuer und viel zu weit weg
daher sind nun zwei deutsche standorte
im gespräch der regionalflughafen
nordholz oder der flughafen rostock
laage
darüber hinaus brachte nun die firma
rocket factory offshore-plattformen
mitten in der nordsee ins gespräch
entweder innerhalb der zwölf meilen zone
oder an der spitze des sogenannten
entenschnabel seinem äußersten punkt der
sogenannten deutschen ausschließlichen
wirtschaftszone die bundesregierung
unterstützt grundsätzlich solche
planspiele ihr raumfahrtkoordinator
weist aber auch auf die hohen hürden hin
die ein weltraumbahnhof egal welcher
größenordnung hierzulande nehmen muss
wir sind dabei mit dem dlr den deutschen
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt genau zu
ergründen was genehmigungsrechtlich
alles erforderlich wäre deutschland ist
ein land mit sehr starken vielen
vorgaben und wo geprüft werden muss vom
grundwasser angefangen bis hin zu der
frage was das für den luftraum zum
beispiel bedeutet er dann frei sein muss
damit man in den weltraum starten kann
oder wenn man beispielsweise über den
möglichkeit in der nordsee redet muss
man am ende halt eben auch den seeraum
frei schaffen
daher würde wenn überhaupt thomas
jarzombek er eine air lounge lösung
bevorzugen bei der eine rakete mit hilfe
eines flugzeuges in höheren
atmosphärenschichten gebracht wird um
sich von dort aus eigener kraft in eine
erdumlaufbahn zu schießen
doch opfern see aus oder von einem
flughafen rostock laage bei der
raumfahrt der zukunft setzt die
bundesregierung inzwischen wie viele
länder auch zunehmend auf privates
engagement aus unserer sicht kommerziell
immer sehr wichtig dass wirklich einer
der anbieter so einen weltraumbahnhof
braucht und sagt ich will den jetzt auch
wirklich haben und betreiben
es macht für uns keinen sinn ein
weltraum bahnhof mit viel aufwand zu
errichten den dann am ende keiner nutzt
insofern sind hier die bedarfsträger
auch ganz weit vorne
auch beim dlr weiß man um die chancen
und risiken kommerzielle raumfahrt dass
es für mini launcher und mini satelliten
einen großen markt gibt davon ist auch
klaus schäfer überzeugt doch die
entwicklungskosten sind enorm und geht
es darum dass diese startups unternehmen
in ihren risiken entlastet werden
nur so gibt es diese venture capital es
gibt reiche leute die einfach ihr privat
kapital einsetzen
die fischer haben in deutschland nicht
also der staat sollte hier
anschubfinanzierung geben
rahmenbedingungen stellen darf die leute
ist einfach hinkriegen
doch sowohl klaus schäfer vom dlr als
auch die ingenieure von high impuls
setzen mittelfristig eher auf eine
europäische problemlösung
immerhin gibt es heute schon in schweden
und norwegen entsprechende startplätze
über dünn besiedelten gebiet weitere
sind in schottland auf den shetland
inseln und auf den azoren geplant so
lange es in deutschland keinen
startplatz gibt werden die schwäbischen
tüftler für ihre geplanten zwölf starts
pro jahr wohl nach skandinavien
ausweichen
es gibt auf jeden fall auch andere
alternativen die in norwegen in schweden
die eben schon startplätze da haben die
schon operationell sind verhören
forschungs raketen und jetzt schon
umgebaut werden für mini launcher die
daneben natürlich weiter sind und auch
weniger entwicklungs geld benötigen auch
weniger europäisches geld in deutschland
müsste man dann eben quasi neu anfangen
damit ein neuanfang für bisher gerade
eine handvoll von startup-unternehmen
auch wenn der markt weiter wächst wird
ein kommerzieller weltraumbahnhof sich
wohl nur dann rechnen wenn er für
raketenbauer aus aller welt gedacht wird
ja und die frage ist so was realistisch
was wir gerade gesehen haben also wir
werden weltraum bahnhöfe wie ich es
immer so schön großartig klingt haben
wir werden andere startplätze haben als
französisch guyana auch in europa davon
bin ich überzeugt aber wir von der esa
aus wir sagen ganz einfach unser
startplatz ist in französisch guyana
aber wenn jetzt länder kommen und von
uns hilfestellungen haben wollen wie zb
die skandinavier oder vielleicht auch
deutschland und polen sind auch genannt
in portugal dann geben wir gerne
hilfestellung aber wir werden nicht eine
europäische neue zusätzliche stationen
aufbauen und im übrigen die meisten
dieser kleinen oder mini raketen oder
mini deutsche die brauchen nicht so
große installationen wie zum beispiel
französisch gelangen
wir sehen gerade einen stolzen
amerikanischen präsidenten
jetzt ist er nicht mehr zu sehen aber
eine große gruppe von journalisten und
der präsident ist jetzt nur gerade so
ein paar dinge abgegangen in trainings
einheit trainingseinheiten city mockups
abgegangen in kanada ja was ist das für
die amerikaner für eine situation jetzt
wir haben immer von der ganz großen nasa
gehört mit der hier auch sehr intensiv
zusammenarbeiten
und jetzt kommt doch plötzlich ein
privates unternehmen es ist immer noch
ein nasa flug es ist nicht ein space
flug
es ist ein langer flug ein auftragnehmer
ja aber wenn wir ganz ernst sind auch
die die apollo rakete ist nicht von nasa
beamten zusammengeschustert worden
sondern natürlich ist die auch von
firmen gebaut worden nur natürlich war
das die steuerung des management sehr
viel enger als hier bei spacex und
tränken aber man kann sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass basics gesagt hat so wir
haben eine rakete die verkaufen wir
jetzt gucken wir fliegen sie mal für
dich sondern die nasa ingenieur innen
und
ingenieure war natürlich auch vor ort
bei ihnen maske und haben geguckt ob die
sicherheitsvorkehrung wirklich auf das
niveau haben was wir für astronomische
raumfahrt brauchen also das ist wirklich
immer noch sehr staatsnah das ist nicht
ein rein privates unternehmen was dann
mal so ein paar raketen zusammenbaut
ich habe jetzt hin becher der von der
letzten mission des space shuttle ist
von der atlantis der grand final sts 135
und wer sich daran erinnert sagt rennen
in den augen der menschen in florida die
wussten das ist nicht nur der letzte
start des space shuttle sondern sie
haben ihren job verloren und die
amerikaner waren deprimiert sie waren
nämlich jetzt plötzlich auf die russen
angewiesen
also ich hatte auch tränenden augen und
zwar weil ich das space shuttle von der
logik her ein unglaublich gutes gerät
fand allerdings und das hat ja reinhold
ewald vorstand gesagt man musste dort in
kauf nehmen man bezahlt die sicherheit
für die astronauten aber man zahlt
dieselbe sicherheit sozusagen für die
ladeluke und das ist natürlich sehr
teuer insofern war das ein modell was
tolle idee war fantastisch wenn man das
auch land sehen das war eine tolle
situation ja ja eigentlich auch eine
gute idee insofern weil man gesagt hat
man kann hin und her ja ja man sollte ja
wirklich im ganz kurzen abstand fliegen
und das war einfach technologisch hat es
dann eben auch ein paar schwierigkeiten
gegeben und es ist eine traurige und
eine tolle geschichte
und deshalb war ich auch traurig als
eingestellt wurde aber wir sollten auch
mal die positive seite sehen die es
durchaus auch gibt nämlich über neun
jahre lang waren wir alle hier in dem
bereich angewiesen auf den russischen
transport und das hat durchaus etwas
gehabt wenn ich mir vorstelle
die krim krise und die möglichkeiten
dass europa die usa und kanada getrennt
fliegen könnten hätten sie das
vermutlich gemacht unter der überschrift
sanktionen
so mussten wir zusammen fliegen und
deshalb fand ich das ganze also ich will
es mal nicht so negativ darstellen
aber es ist trotzdem wichtig meine jetzt
nicht ich will das nicht negativ
darstellen aber das gefühl mit den
amerikanern war ja schon danach um
gottes willen jetzt müssen wir mit der
sie ihre
fliegen und der stellvertretende chef
der nase hat damals gesagt sie glauben
gar nicht wie schnell die preise für
diese transporte hoch gegangen sind von
den russen
wir sind jetzt plötzlich abhängig von
denen also das war auch nicht nur
finanziell sondern auch von der vom
image her für die abmahnindustrie
emotionen sozusagen die abhängigkeit
wirklich sichtbar gemacht ja es gibt
auch heute noch amerikanische raketen
bei denen triebwerke aus dem früheren
ostblock verwandt werden also ist nicht
so dass das alles vollkommen unabhängig
ist aber es war richtig es war für die
amerikaner ein schock aber wie gesagt
ich sehe auch durchaus positive aspekte
dieses schocks ist es war aber auch so
not invented here moment wo man sagt
also das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren
dies so ist und wie viel haben wir
gelernt von dassow oz wie wie robust ist
dieses system hat das vor anderthalb
jahren über oktober ja bewiesen mitten
im flug ein über 20 jahren nicht
gebraucht das system hat prima
funktioniert
zwei kollegen gerettet solche dinge muss
man erst mal bauen und auch die
internationale raumstation attig von der
raumstation bin ich ja nun dritter zeuge
was wir damals an opera operations also
an betrieb dieser raumstation gelernt
haben dass das hat doch überhaupt erst
dieser iss ermöglicht also gar nicht
hingucken ist nicht gut ist nicht von
uns wir machen american soll american
rockets und american as st ich kann man
sicherlich sehr froh und was sie auch
geärgert hat war die sojus startete
immer unglaublich pünktlich wir sind mal
gespannt ob das heute klappt denn das
wäre natürlich auch ein ziemlich großer
rückschlag sie haben die mir ja schon
angesprochen fünfundzwanzigster februar
1997 reinhold ewald sein erster flug ins
all
reinhold ewald wissenschafts astronaut
am 10 februar beginnt sein aufenthalt in
der russischen raumstation mir
seit elf jahren und kreis mir die erde
bilder vom andocken
technische probleme gab es in der alten
aber soliden raumstation schon öfter
nicht nur bei der fernsehübertragung
es gab stromausfälle und schwierigkeit
mit den versorgungssystemen vorgestern
22 35 bauzeit der bisher gefährlichste
zwischenfall eine sauerstoff patrone
sollte gewechselt werden um die luft
aufzufrischen
was geschah dann 20 stunden danach
reinhold ewald per ton leitung die
anderen organisierten aufgezwungen sogar
nur darum möglichst viel licht luft aus
dieser gas masse verbraucht damit die
dauer dieser markt eben verlängert ohne
so haben wir dann sein hat für mich
dieser gas geben abend arbeiten können
die installation ersetzt hier
aufgegriffen und die luft an den größten
befreit hatten
dass man also endlich wieder von
normalen zinssatz werden konnte
neldel spielt und ich habe darauf
gedrängt wirklich diese anleitung zu
befolgen
die leute geredet kommando rahmen geben
also die anforderungen der situation die
nehmen einen in anspruch dass man gar
nichts anderes denken kann
eigentlich erlebt und die augen
offenhalten lehmann die pro land gehen
kann ich was hätte im schlimmsten fall
an dort passieren können module der
toyota tun schlechter wenn ein teil der
raumstation nicht mehr sicher gewesen
wäre hätten sie sich in eines der
angedockten raumschiffe gerettet sagt
ewald hätten dort auf das verlöschen des
brandes gewartet und wären dann mit
sauerstoffmasken in die station zurück
gekehrt die verbindung zur mehrere ist
immer nur für minuten möglich als die
station bei der erdumkreisung außer
reichweite gerät bricht die leitung ab
[Applaus]
reinhold vielen dank deswegen hat wie
warten das damals wir haben ja so einen
schönen spruch bei fliegern heißt es
immer naja mit dem fliegen ist das halt
so man kann da nicht an die seitenlinie
vom mit dem auto fahren und dann mal am
parkplatz anhalten da gibt's sofort
wirklich eine ganz ganz schwierige
situation wenn er dinge zusammenkommen
jetzt haben wir einen solchen situation
die sie aufgeschrieben haben jetzt
gerade im gespräch mit schlegel
was ist denn das für ein gefühl fühlt
man sich da völlig hilflos nein also
eine kalte hand hat mich da eigentlich
nicht angepackt dass man hat ja die
möglichkeiten schon im training
vorgeführt bekommen bekommen sich aus
einer solchen situation zu retten also
vergiftete atmosphäre oder oder feuer
das wird natürlich nicht ernst genommen
wenn man da mit nur so tut als ob man
ein feuer löscht das wurde natürlich
nicht in gänze dargestellt das haben wir
dann nachher als input fürs training
gesagt wir müssen da mal wirklich durch
durch seine situation und wir haben es
wirklich nach lehrbuch gemacht wir haben
wirklich gesagt selbstschutz zuerst
versammeln wer macht was
eine feuerwehr kette gebildet sozusagen
die feuerlöscher nach vorne gegeben
nicht alle
ich kann es besser sondern wie ich das
dann auch geschildert habe wirklich nach
nach lehrbuch abgewartet was sind unsere
nächsten schritte
das werden die hier auch machen wenn sie
eine fehlfunktion haben da ist vieles
automatisch inzwischen da setzt dann das
reservesystem ein oder es wird ein weg
drumherum programmiert so zu sagen aber
letztlich ist die crew immer mit den
augen mit den ohren mit mit auch dem
ganzen körper dabei zusehen passt das
was jetzt was ich jetzt hier erlebe
zudem momentan flugzustand oder muss ich
irgendwas nach checken oder oder sogar
melden
das heißt die nervosität oder so die
unsicherheit die entstehen könnte wird
einfach dadurch abgepuffert dass man von
vornherein weiß das muss jetzt getan
werden und auch die sozusagen
befehlskette ist klar
in dem falle ja also das muss man
wirklich sagen wir haben ja eben schon
darauf hingewiesen die iss ist ein
wissenschaftliches labor
da kann man natürlich nicht wissenschaft
verordnen da kann man nicht morgens die
parole aus
geben du löst dieses problem der
wissenschaften und die justiz das
problem sondern das ist ja eine q/q
aktion die am abend des tages zusammen
gebracht wie weit sind wir mit dem
tagesprogramm gekommen und dann gibt es
tatsächlich aber die autorität stelle
die kommandantin denken kommandanten der
das ganze dann mit houston die haben die
ober verantwortung dann kommuniziert und
das ist eine sehr verantwortliche
position in dem fall nicht nicht nur in
notsituationen sondern auch gerade für
den täglichen ablauf den rücken stärken
sehen wo ist jemand überlastet wo wohin
jemand hinter dem zeitplan her das sind
die dinge die in so ner befehlskette
wichtiger sind als ich habe das kommando
und ich mache jetzt den solo es ist ja
eigentlich bei der tatsache dass wir es
hier in diesen verschiedenen phasen der
raumfahrt immer mit der dem letzten
stand der technik zu tun gehabt haben
überraschend auch wenn es schlimm war
dass es so verhältnismäßig wenig unfälle
gegeben hat na ja also das wollte würde
ich jetzt nicht kleinreden die das
shuttle war schon erschütternd und ich
kam hier an beide das volumen waren
beide unfälle erinnern ich war bei
komarov so wie es einst war ich zu jung
da habe ich nicht hingeguckt auch die
anderen unfälle bei rückkehr und jedes
mal hat es dazu geführt dass
grundsätzlich das system was versagt hat
oder die ganz der ganze ablauf
revolutioniert wurde dass man das
wirklich im kopf gestellt hatten da
müssen wir uns als astronauten darauf
verlassen können dass ein solches viel
vor sagt eines systems wirklich dann
auch so gründlich behoben wird das nicht
geflickt wird sondern dass das
grundsätzlich auch erneuert wird
übrigens vom ersten bis zum 2 shuttle
unglück hat man vieles noch entdeckt was
leider eine wiederholung des ersten
unglücks war und das ist eigentlich
nicht das was man in der
systementwicklung hier erwartet als
astronaut das hat ja auch immer wieder
dann längere pausen gegeben es musste
alles im grunde genommen noch neu
geprüft werden wobei man beim space
shuttle ja von den astronauten immer
gehört hat vor allen dingen von denen
die es geflogen haben das ist nun
wirklich das am schwersten zu fliegende
objekt was man
menschen haben je entwickelter derart
grandios ich meine eine landung des
space-shuttle da kommt dieser goldene
vogel kommt der großen schleife über
kennedy space center da habe ich es
erlebt noch in der letzten abend sondern
und minuten später bricht ein schulbus
großes objekt aus dem all
ungebremst auf diese landebahn mein
kollege gerd thiele hat mal gesagt der
shuttle ist als raumfahrzeug von den
aerodynamik gekapert worden da sollte
also doch noch sein fliegerisches
element sollte erhalten werden aber es
war einfach grandios zu sehen aber aus
dem beben schon aufgezählten grund zu
teuer zu risikoreich und nachher auch
und effektiv man musste immer zwei
shuttle auf der startrampe
wenn eins scheiterte dass man die kugel
wieder abholen konnte damit war das
unproduktiv schauen wir auf die ja
leider auch tragödien in der raumfahrt
aber auch auf ganz großartige ja
wunderschöne momente wo es dann doch
noch im letzten augenblick geklappt hat
er war das ziel von apollo 13 der mond
die mission begann am abend des 11
april 1970 nach der erfolgreichen
mondlandung von neil armstrong und buzz
aldrin sollten nun jim leyland face den
mond betreten und dort weitere
experimente durchführen
doch es kam ganz anders am frühen morgen
des 14 april erzeugte das thermostat
eines sauerstofftanks einen kurzschluss
der tank explodiert und beschädigte die
raumfähre ort ist so stark dass die crew
die mehrtägige reise durchs all dort
nicht überlebt hätte am 14 april 1981
landet die columbia ein triumph der
us-raumfahrt das erste wiederverwendbare
trägersystem schafft einen taxi verkehr
zwischen erde und umlaufbahn wird so ein
shuttle system zur internationalen
raumstation
am ersten februar 2003 kommt es zur
katastrophe
16 minuten vor der geplanten landung der
colombia und es ist gespenstisch still
im kontrollzentrum von houston
und sie versuchen es noch einmal
doch die einzige antwort ist das
rauschen des shuttle radios keiner der
sieben astronauten meldet sich
[Applaus]
flugdirektor leroy cain ahnt dass etwas
nicht stimmt melden sich die
hydraulische systeme zurück sagt er
nein wir haben auch das buch getriebe
verloren sie antworten möchte dass vier
temperaturregler ausgestiegen sind
das system spinnt wir haben die daten
verloren
dann hätten wir ein radarbild haben
müssen
schon vor einer minute
der funkkontakt ist abgebrochen und die
columbia gerade explodiert diese neuen
bilder aufgenommen aus einem
hubschrauber zeigen wie das spaceshuttle
in viele teile zerbricht und schließlich
abstürzte
in diesem moment erfährt der chef der
bodenzentrale dass es dafür augenzeugen
gibt und er weiß leroy cain dass es
vorbei ist schließt die türen sagt er zu
seinen leuten aus der angst ist
gewissheit geworden es ist der moment in
dem auch ein nasa man mal weint
statt der landung wird nun die
katastrophe organisiert keine telefonate
aus diesem raum keine gespräche auf
diesen leitungen hier keine
datenweitergabe es gehen keine
übertragungen rein oder raus so kurz
vorm ziel ist alles zu ende was bleibt
ist die bergung der trümmer können sie
bestätigen das und um dallas leute
mobilisiert worden sind um uns zu helfen
es ist der tag den der nasa-ingenieur
immer gefürchtet hat leroy cain kann
jetzt nur noch beten für die crew und
für ihre familien ja professor
schreckliche momente für nicht nur
diejenigen die doch drin saßen und
verantwortlich war sondern auch für alle
die mit der raumfahrt eine verbindung
hatten wir haben sie das damals erlebt
ich habe es im radio gehört
beim spaziergang und habe sofort meine
frau gesagt sorry dass ich gehen cent um
damals in köln
wir müssen darauf reagieren und
tatsächlich wurden quasi schon von
fernsehteams von radio teams in empfang
genommen und haben versucht zumindest
die fakten im vordergrund zu stellen was
ist bekannt was warum könnte eine solche
katastrophe passieren
das hat er erst nach und nach das puzzle
hat ja dann gestalt angenommen
und da nicht jetzt vorstellen beschlüsse
oder das ende der raumfahrt oder
ähnliches zu verkünden also das war
unsere pflicht gegenüber den sieben
kolleginnen und kollegen die zu tode
gekommen ist
es ist aber trotzdem auch noch einmal
eine besondere situation wenn man
wahrscheinlich als astronaut selber sich
vorstellen kann was da passiert ist
ja und trotzdem ist thomas reiter 2006
dann in den zweiten flug wieder
eingestiegen man hat das offen behandelt
das problem man hat die die schwächen
erkannt man hat sicherungsmaßnahmen
eingeführt die das shuttle system sehr
uneffektiv machten wie gesagt die zweite
rettungsmission immer auf dem start und
nur noch flüge zur raumstation bis auf 1
der zum hubble space telescope ging das
hat natürlich den sozusagen schon die
glocke geläutet dass man sich irgendwann
von diesen teuren aber aber schön und
gewaltigen gefährt eigentlich
verabschieden musste ja ich höre
natürlich sofort ist ein schönes gefährt
gewesen space shuttle ist keine frage
trotzdem was mich jetzt noch mal
interessiert weil wir ja jetzt zu der
alten form eigentlich wieder
zurückgekommen sind könnte man sich
irgendwann so eine art von space shuttle
noch mal vorstellen
ich glaube ja und da gibt es ja auch
schon arbeiten dafür also wir haben in
der esa zum beispiel eine ein projekt
dhs base weiter da wollen wir ein
kleines shuttle bauen allerdings erstmal
ohne astronauten ein kleines winziges
shuttle speziell für experimente und wir
sind auch mit an mit den engländern
insbesondere im gespräch die wollen eine
mischung bauen aus einem flugzeug mit
einem flugzeug motor und einem raketen
motor skyliners und dass wir auch so ein
gefährt was starten und landen kann auf
einer piste aber zwischendurch bis ins
weltall ich glaube das wird die zukunft
auch wieder zeigen
so schön diese diese kapseln von dem von
den raumfahrt ingenieuren gesehen werden
weil sie auch so schön sicher wieder
zurückkommen ich glaube werden
irgendwann wieder zu anderen gefährten
kommen wenn nicht nur in den science
fiction filmen sondern auch in der
realität und wir haben eben gesehen dass
der amerikanische präsident oder tram
gelandet ist und er ist jetzt zu einer
pressekonferenz mit spacex chef und
tesla chef elon musk zusammen
aufgetreten
ich möchte allen danken ist ein freund
von mir schon seit langem ich habe
großen respekt vor ihm er arbeitet ja
immer rund um die uhr denkt über viele
sachen nach ja das ist auf jeden fall
das schwierigste
also
die top priorität ist die einzige brite
das ist sicherheit jetzt für uns das
sieht super aus
wir halten uns noch zurück mit
glückwünschen weil wir haben ja noch
eine zeit prozess sieht aber super aus
denn sie haben das projekt aus den
kinderschuhen bis hierhin entwickelt und
ursprünglich hatten wir hier mal gras
aus den spalten der lande- und
startbahnen wachsen sehen
jetzt ist besser ich denke auch mike
pence der sehr hart daran gearbeitet hat
dass das jetzt hier möglich ist toller
job mag ich möchte allen hier danken das
ist etwas auf das die first lady und ich
uns sehr gefreut haben und in kurzer
zeit gibt es den start und werden wir es
wettermäßig schaffen jim ja keine
einwände bisher also das hört sich toll
an ich hoffe es wird ihnen gefallen
vielen dank ich möchte auch noch was
sagen ich möchte wirklich sehr klar
sagen welche transformation der
stattgefunden hat haben kennedy space
center bob cabana war direktor dieses
zentrums wie lange neun jahre 9 12 jahre
und es gab eine zeit in unserem land
ministerpräsident vor rund neun jahren
als die space shuttle aus dem verkehr
gezogen wurden und die vereinigten
staaten seitdem keinen zugang zum
weltall haben zu bewaffnen zur bemannten
raumfahrt
dieser bereich lag wirklich in trümmern
und wir haben damals auch das
mondprogramm gecancelt und gestrichen
werden ein großartiges programm laufen
also bob kaper hat wirklich harte arbeit
geleistet in diesen zeiten jetzt haben
wir großartige unterstützung seitens der
regierung
das nasa budget so hoch wie höher als je
zuvor wir bringen amerika wieder zurück
in die
mantel raumfahrt und es ist die zeiten
sind vorbei in denen hier das gras aus
dem beton books wir haben nicht nur die
politischen direktiven von der regierung
wir haben jetzt auch das budget um
diesen politischen anweisungen
nachzukommen und die vorherrschaft
amerikas im weltall zu sichern
das war ein brillanter schachzug des
präsidenten dass er das im national
weltraum grad so durchgesetzt hat ich
möchte auch wirklich klar stellen heute
ist ein großartiger tag für die nation
und das liegt an ihrer arbeit elend die
sie auch schon lange gearbeitet haben
wir müssen eine führungsmacht in der
welt sein und das ist ja ein wichtiger
schritt
vielen dank möglich dass sich noch was
sein
tja die bildregie hatte da auch mal
einige probleme kann das sein dass wir
jetzt äußerungen haben die vielleicht
auf den november hindeuten nämlich auf
die wahlen in den usa waren das
politische äußerungen
ich bin chef der europäischen
raumfahrt-agentur und nicht chef
irgendeiner politischen partei ist denn
das so wie gerade beschrieben dass die
amerikaner die vorherrschaft im weltraum
wieder nicht nur angestrebt haben
sondern auch erreicht haben also es ist
doch klar dass wir haben's ja auch
gehört das nasa budget ist wirklich
enorm und man kann dann nur gratulieren
und es ist ja nicht nur das nasa budget
was für die raumfahrt da es die
amerikaner haben ja weitere budgets also
allein in das nasa budget ist ja schon
mehr als 20 milliarden dollar pro jahr
zum vergleich wir reden in der esa von
etwas über sechs milliarden
euro pro jahr also das ist schon ein
unterschied aber ich denke auch die
europäer brauchen sich nicht zu
verstecken
wir haben viele nationale und
europäische projekte insbesondere auch
in der frage zum beispiel der
satellitennavigation der erdbeobachtung
der telekommunikation in der
astronomischen raumfahrt haben wir bei
weitem nicht so viel geld wie die nasa
das ist bedauerlich finde es auch ganz
schön wenn europa da an der stelle auch
mehr machen
nun ist ja auch einiges wir haben eben
über die funktion und die rolle der ss
gesprochen
einiges was die esa zum beispiel macht
wirklich sehr hilfreich für uns menschen
etwa in der klimaforschung los ist
gestartet worden
ein satellit der untersuchen soll wie
unser wetter aber vor allen dingen auch
die windbedingungen sich verändern das
ist ja eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr
auf der erde alles nach zu kontrollieren
und zu dokumentieren da muss man ja
eigentlich solche satelliten haben die
könnten ja existenziell wichtig sagen
über 50 prozent der sogenannten klima
variablen die essenziell sind für den
klimawandel können wir nur aus dem
weltall beobachten also deshalb das ist
der weltraum ist dafür unabdingbar wenn
wir klimawandel wirklich beobachten
wollen sie haben alle lose genannt da
los ist eine meisterleistung an sich hat
lange gedauert bis es funktioniert hat
ist nämlich ein laser an bord und sowie
die radarkontrollen beim auf dem
straßenverkehr so arbeitet dieser
satellit meter sind die amerikaner daran
gescheitert
ja ich wollte es nicht so deutlich sagen
wo sie können das ja gesagt
unsere amerikanischen freunde haben es
versucht sage ich mal positiv europa hat
es geschafft wir haben ein bisschen
gebraucht dafür das war sehr schwierig
und wir haben auch gleich gedacht als
wahllos gestartet hatten und die ersten
messungen kamen o kriegen wir auch ein
problem aber er arbeitet perfekt was
allerdings ein anderes problem war mit
der eos wir sind fast zusammengestoßen
mit einem satelliten von herrn mas das
ist dann ein anderes thema bei dem wir
in zukunft aufpassen müssen wir brauchen
nämlich diesen satelliten zur
erdbeobachtung und da dürfen wir uns
keine unfälle im weltall erlauben denn
es gibt ja pläne für satelliten die
nun internet verbreiten sollen et cetera
und das sind so viele dass es
wahrscheinlich irgendwann ein bisschen
eng werden dürfte da oben wir hatten
wird wir hatten bisher etwa 400.000
satelliten im all
von denen waren 1500 aktiv also 3000
nicht aktiv das ist schon eine große
zahl an mast plant jetzt 42.000 nur er
für seine mega konstellation
und wenn wir davon ausgehen dass nur
eine zahl von zehn prozent vielleicht
nicht funktioniert dann sind das über
4000 und es gibt noch andere firmen die
auch solche mega concessions bauen
wollen also das ist ein ernst zu
nehmendes thema wir brauchen da oben
bessere vorfahrtsregeln
und wir brauchen auch etwas um
weltraumschrott deutlich zu entsorgen
und die asse hat dafür auch eine mission
jetzt gestartet oder eine planung
durchführung mit einer kleinen
unternehmen übrigens ganz ähnlich wie
das vielleicht spacex macht von der
logik nämlich wir haben einen service
eingekauft von einem kleinen unternehmen
von einem start up wir sehen dass da
sich etwas getan hat deutet das darauf
hin dass ist mit dem start klappen
könnte hat so ein paar entscheidende
punkte der stadt timeline sind jetzt
eingetreten
zum einen hat man das wetter
offensichtlich als noch chancenreich
eingestuft und hat zumindest mal die
erlaubnis gegeben dass jetzt der
flüssigen sauerstoff und das hoch
verdichtete kerosin in die kammern der
falcon 1 eingeleitet werden das macht
man natürlich nicht wenn man damit der
abgerechnet in fünf minuten abbrechen zu
müssen denn das ist ja ein vorgang der
wirklich auch sehr sorgfältig
durchgeführt werden muss wir werden also
in kürze sehen dass sich wolken bilden
an der rakete das ist kondenswasser wir
sind ja an einem strand wir sind in der
nähe des meeres und damit unvermeidlich
natürlich bei diesen kalten treibstoffen
dass sich das kondenswasser bildet
außerdem muss der kuh arm der bis jetzt
den zugang zu der kapsel zu der
inzwischen verschlossenen luke
garantiert hat er muss natürlich
zurückgefahren werden im gegenzug sind
die triebwerke der kapsel
selbst dragon die der ersten draco also
war bleibt in der in der bezeichnung
welt in der symbol welt diese triebwerke
sind jetzt scharf geschaltet und das ist
eigentlich eine interessante geschichte
denn die ursprüngliche lande sequenz des
regen sah vor dass der auf triebwerken
auf einem triebwerk strahlt er auf dem
land nieder geht es war sogar die rede
davon dass das die triebwerke sind die
man schon auf dem weg zum mars oder bei
der landung auf dem mars benutzen wollte
und davon ist man wieder abgekommen
die konstrukteure der kollegen haben
dann fallschirme eingeführt also anders
als bei der falken ein erster stufe
werden wir wenn dann diese katze
zurückgeht zurückkommt werden wir sehen
dass die einen fallschirm im wasser
landet aber übrig geblieben sind diese
ganz starken triebwerk diese drei
triebwerke die jetzt dazu benutzt werden
die kuh im falle eines versagens der
trägerrakete sehr schnell von diesen
explodierenden objekt weg zu schleudern
bis zum letzten augenblick gibt es immer
wieder situationen die trainiert werden
wenn es einen notfall gibt wir sind mal
dabei gewesen als vor dem start von
alexander gerst zu seiner mission in
houston ein solches notfalltraining
durchgeführt worden ist und das war ein
training da ging es unter anderem darum
was passiert denn eigentlich wenn es ein
loch gibt und genau das wurde trainiert
was später tatsächlich auf der als es
passiert ist
alarm auf der iss besonders gefordert
ist gerst als erster deutscher übernimmt
der zeit war sie das kommando über die
iss
die korrupt vorfälle die tödlich enden
können
nein
die technik meldet ein leck in der us
sektion der iss das loch winzig ist
bedeutet dass lebensgefahr
nico muss es schnellstens finden und
abdichten hier beim üben noch begleitet
und überwacht von den astronauten
trennen
dafür wolle price laptop diesen orten
stehen
es geht
die abläufe sind minutiös festgelegt
jeder astronaut muss sie einhalten
konzentriert gehen alexander gerst und
seine crew mitglieder die notfallübung
durch
wo ist das leck als nächstes wird das
harmony modell überprüft laut
übungsablauf wird die zeit nun knapp
jetzt ruhen bereits schwere schäden an
der technik
nun werden die schotten geschlossen um
die folgen des lecks zu begrenzen
[Musik]
doch trotz aller maßnahmen der druck
nimmt weiter bedrohlich ab
das leck ist nicht gefunden die crew
regelt weitere station styleheads gmbh
der druck sinkt immer weiter gerd dyck
überprüfen nun die letzten sektion der
ss immer näher kommen sie dem tödlichen
loch das die gesamte station zerstören
kann
die geräte schlagen an nun ist der
moment an dem sich erfolg oder
misserfolg entscheiden
unter den prüfenden augen der
astronauten trainer arbeiten sich die
astronauten voran bis sie dem leck immer
näher kommen
noch haben sie weitere geräte die
anzeigen können wo sich das recht genau
befindet jeder handgriff jedes detail
ihres vorgehens wird aufgezeichnet
nun bleibt nur noch eine ganz bestimmte
stelle übrig hier könnte es sein letzte
überprüfung am ende ist die
erleichterung groß
der stress entlädt sich auch bei den
stress profis in einem lachen
[Musik]
spannende situation wir haben erlebt
dass auch sehr klar da die hierarchie
war also da gab es einen der sagte
nämlich alexander gerst was zu tun ist
stimmt und das ist eben genau die das
wichtig in der situation dass da jetzt
nicht diskutiert wird oder heldentum
habe ich da über funk benannt
ausgespielt wird sondern dass man
wirklich das nötige tut und das geht nur
wenn jeder eine festgelegte rolle hat
und jede und die erfahrung der gruppe
sozusagen bei einer person ankommt die
dann die weiteren entscheidungen
kommuniziert und so haben was auch bei
dem feuer gehalten dass das also klar
war wer das weitere bestimmt aber sich
ab stimmte mit allen anderen das klingt
trivial aber wenn ich da kurz was sagen
kann mittel für mich ist das immer
wieder beeindrucken wenn ich mit den
astronauten rede weil diese fähigkeit
sozusagen drei unterschiedliche rollen
je nach situation machen zu können
nämlich einmal teammitglied ganz fern
jeder sagt kann ich einmal chef sagt
auch noch der meister kann ich auch und
einmal follower zu sagen okay der chef
hat gesagt ich soll das jetzt machen ich
mache es gebe zu ich könnte nicht alle
drei funktionen
sie konnten sich nicht unterordnen ich
habe nichts gesagt aber ich glaube das
wäre ein problem ja immer die frage was
geht einem durch den kopf also die mir
ist zum beispiel auch durch den kopf
gegangen erstes kann ja an
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen sammeln
das heißt in dem moment wo man mal eine
minute nicht jetzt akut dass die gefahr
bekämpft habe ich will schon angefangen
datenträger in den anzug zu stopfen
falls es zu einer evakuierung kommt der
andere gedanke ist hoffentlich wenn als
für einen durch waren hoffentlich kommt
die gute nachricht dass
letztlich der flug fortgesetzt werden
kann niemand zu schaden gekommen ist vor
der schlechten nachricht an da oben ist
was passiert aber wir wissen noch nicht
was das heißt die familienmitglieder da
unten sind vielmehr im ungewissen und
vielmehr in der in sorge wenn eine
solche teil nachricht nur durch kommt
als die oma uns interessante fun fact
bei diesem flug beide
besatzungsmitglieder sind mit
astronautinnen verheiratet und wobei die
eindeutig kvist hat sogar eine
langzeitmissionen an bord einer
raumstation absolviert alle anderen
haben kürzere shuttle-flüge gemacht also
die wissen wirklich die familien wissen
wovon sie reden und haben das wirklich
da noch einordnen können wird
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen dazu
dass man ein bisschen verständnis für
das hat was dort passiert verständnis
auch im sinne von dass es ja hier auch
lange trainingsphasen gibt in denen man
eben nicht zu hause ist richtig und das
mit nur zwei astronauten eltern familie
möchte ich mir also gar nicht vorstellen
wie hat ihre familie damals reagiert
fand die das auch etwas anstrengend dass
sie dann ständig zu trainings unterwegs
war
das ist gehört dazu also dass das muss
man klären wenn man dazu nicht bereit
ist und wenn man da nicht den rückhalt
auch der familie hat so wie es hatte ist
es unsinn sich auf solch eine
lange strecke zu begeben denn heutzutage
heißt das ja zweieinhalb jahre vor dem
eigentlichen flug aus dem koffer
zwischen houston zu kuba das ist das
japanische raumfahrtzentrum köln moskau
hin und her pendeln also das ist teil
des großen abenteuers dass man also
wirklich nur als kollektiv als familie
dann gemeinsam angehen können
wir haben gerade den schönen strand
direkt in cape canaveral gesehen
cocoa beach das ist eine sehr schöne
gegend wenn man auch nicht darum laufen
sollte weil die alligatoren die da sind
die bewachen auch das gelände sehr genau
und die schlangen die dort existieren
und das ist meistens ziemlich heiß warum
gibt es diesen unterschied zwischen der
russischen raumfahrt und amerikanischen
raumfahrt und wir haben eben über kurucz
und gesprochen
warum gehen die russen in eine steppe
und starten dort und landen die auch auf
dem land nicht wie amerika da hilft die
geografie weiter nehmen sie eine
landkarte und gucken sie mal welche
bereiche russland zur verfügung hätte
dicht am äquator
und das ist nicht viel insofern sind die
eben nach kasachstan gegangen bauen
jetzt ein neues system auf ganz im osten
aber sie sind halt weiterhin relativ
weit im norden und was ich vorhin gesagt
habe bezüglich der günstigen situation
ehemann am äquator ist umso besser ist
es der die kasachische steppe hat
natürlich den vorteil dass es
menschenleer ist oder sagen wir mal
menschen arm lieber es gibt dort
natürlich auch siedlung aber dass auch
eine voraussetzung wenn man raketen
startet dann möchte man ganz gerne nicht
durch höhere gegebenenfalls
herunterfallende bruchstücke menschen
gefährden auf der erde
und deshalb ist auch dafür eine steppe
durchaus ein geeigneter ort und in
florida wie auch in französisch guyana
starten wir richtung mehr wir starten
nicht richtung land und das hat
erhebliche vorteile das wird man ja auch
so schnell nicht ändern also die die
russen haben ja wahrscheinlich so über
mal geguckt und haben gesagt man würde
mir eigentlich ganz gerne in die gegend
auch gehen oder ja also sie fliegen ja
von französisch-guyana fliegt ja auch
die seriös mit einer größeren
leistungsfähigkeit wir folgen
angesprochen haben und wie gesagt die
russen bauen derzeit ein anderes system
auf im ganzen osten
letztlich ist baikonur ist ja nicht
russland ist ja kasachstan und die
russen bezahlen dafür relativ viel geld
damit sie von dort fliegen dürfen und
das wollen sie loswerden diesen lassen
und immer gesehen da wäldchen wo muss
man vorsichtig zu sagen also ziemlich
große wolken ist das der unterschied
zwischen dem tropischen klima
subtropischen klima und leben was da an
ja das ist die feuchtigkeit feuchtigkeit
also die am stand natürlich da ist und
sich jetzt an dem kalten treibstoff aber
an dem viele viel kälteren noch
sauerstoff niederschlägt die haben sogar
noch ein paar grad darauf gegeben was
minus temperaturen angeht um eine höhere
dichte dieses sauerstoff zu erreichen um
diese tanks also wirklich komplett voll
zu machen und das sehen wir hier als
resultate der wird natürlich immer der
überdruck auch kontrolliert abgelassen
und sobald das passiert bilden sich
content zwecken und auch eis und das war
ja fatal beim shuttle wir können mal
schauen nach houston und da sehe ich
matthias maurer den esa astronauten der
im training in houston es schönen guten
abend
einen schönen guten abend oder ich muss
ja eigentlich sagen schon gut nachmittag
weil ich bin sieben stunden dahinter und
sie sind mitten im training was machen
sie im augenblick ja ich bin in houston
astronautenzentrum und ich habe ein
normales regelmäßiges training wir
müssen ja jedes jahr gucken dass wir fit
bleiben und morgens früh springe ich
wieder in den großen raum anzug und dann
übe ich einen weltraumspaziergang unter
wasser in einem folien houston
was ist dieses wahrscheinlich größte
buzzer was es auf der welt gibt von
süßwasser wo ja quasi fast eine ganze 1
rein passt warum muss man da tauchen ja
schwerelosigkeit kann man auf der erde
sehr schlecht simulieren man kann es auf
zwei arten erzeugen das eine ist ein
flugzeug das sage ich mal wellen lienig
fliegt etwas was der normale passagiere
im flugzeug gar nicht mag
und dann hat man circa 22 sekunden
schwerelosigkeit am stück und dann ist
man wieder doppelt so schwer
das heißt es sehr sehr wenig zeit um
etwas zu trainieren
deswegen gehen die astronauten im
training unter wasser und wir sind dann
sechs stunden in unserem raumanzug unter
wasser und üben dann in einen
weltraumspaziergang wir sind dann quasi
schwerelos unter wasser und das ist das
beste gefühl dass man zu
trainingszwecken auf der erde erzeugen
kann
das beste gefühl zu trennen zwecken aber
macht das gefühl spaß weil es gibt jetzt
ganz viele nicht nur in deutschland die
warten auf ihren tauchurlaub macht ihnen
so etwas dann noch spaß im training ja
also das ist ein bisschen gemischt es
macht natürlich super spaß weil das gibt
einem so dass das gefühl der mann ist
hautnah dran also der nächste schritt
ist nur noch der weltraum aber sechs
stunden in diesem raum einzug und ich
trage da auf pampers und wenn ich auf
toilette muss dann nutze ich diese
pampers dann auch man ist da eingeengt
eingequetscht und das ist harte
körperliche arbeit also das ist so ein
bisschen wenn die sechs stunden vorbei
sind dann dann bin ich auch erleichtert
es ist ja das training für einen
ausstieg
und diese ausschläge sind ja notwendig
um auch an der iss reparaturen
vorzunehmen
das ist aber dann ein schweben im
weltraum wenn es auf sie zukäme wären
sie jetzt im hinblick darauf auf die
perspektive eher nervös oder würden sie
sagen mit das würde ich glaube wirklich
mal gerne erleben also ein schwätzer
spaziergang ist der größte traum für
einen astronauten der erste die erste
stufe ist erst einmal in den weltraum zu
fliegen
und der nächste schritt ist dann
wirklich ganz ganz nah dran sein man hat
ja ein visier mit einer ganz dünnen
scheibe nur zwischen sich und dem balkon
und das ist das was die astronomie
alle wirklich erleben wollen von den
beiden astronauten der nasa die heute
starten werden hatte öffentlich starten
wird einer auch welt seine schützlinge
durchführen und zwar steht auf der
planung dass er zusammen mit dem
kollegen der jetzt schon auf der
raumstation iss die batterien austauscht
das ist jetzt ja schon in den letzten
zwei drei jahren sehr intensiv verfolgt
und das wäre dann der letzte abschnitt
um die alten batterien oder die alten
akkus auf der station durch die neuen
effizienteren batterien auszutauschen
sie sind ja jetzt zwar in houston nicht
näher dran an florida unbedingt was
jetzt die entfernung an betritt aber sie
sind ja emotional wahrscheinlich sehr
nah dran
sie sind ja einer der nächsten der
fliegen wird wenn sie so ein start jetzt
doch zehn übermittelt von den bildern in
florida was ist denn das für ein gefühl
würden sie da jetzt schon am liebsten
mit dabei sein
ja also bei dem staat jetzt hier bin ich
eigentlich ganz froh dass ich das von
außen sehen kann erst einmal diese
profis ran zu lassen das ist ja beides
testingenieure testpiloten und test
ingenieur und die sollen diese kapsel
auf herz und nieren überprüfen das dann
alles funktioniert und dann nach dem
erfolgreichen flug und wenn die kapsel
sozusagen geprüft ist dann können dann
auch die normalen astronauten wie ich
dann dort einsteigen und dann mit
fliegen zur raumstation also ich bin
natürlich gespannt und drücke den beiden
kollegen ganz ganz fest die daumen dass
das alles klappt dass sie sicher zur
station kommen und dann auch sicher
wieder zurück zur erde
und wenn dieser meilenstein geschafft
ist dann werden die nächsten ernennungen
auch wieder möglich sein momentan ist ja
alles so ein bisschen auf halt und der
nächste europäer der in den weltraum
fliegen sollte ist mein kollege thomas g
und ich denke der sitzt jetzt genauso
gespannt vom bildschirm wie ich und wir
beide drücken fest die daumen dass
dieser staat heute klappt ist ja
wahrscheinlich kein zufall dass das
zwei testpiloten sind die jetzt die
felgen neuen fliegen denn man hatte ja
früher fast nur aus der amerikanischen
luftwaffe piloten geflogen sind und dann
kam immer mehr dann auch der
wissenschaftler dazu hat das jetzt die
bedeutung dass es tatsächlich von test
piloten geflogen werden soll die
natürlich sich über eine solche
situation besser oder in einer solchen
situation besser auskennen
im normalzustand fliegt diese kapsel
vollkommen automatisch und die
astronauten die dann mit der steuerung
beauftragt sind die sollten eigentlich
nur noch überwachen
also manuell wird hier eigentlich sehr
wenig erwartet wenn alles normal läuft
heute ist natürlich ein sonderfall weil
heute soll diese kapsel staaten uns
nicht einfach nur zur raumstation
fliegen als wäre in wenigen stunden
möglich sondern die beiden kollegen die
heute drin sitzen die sollen wirklich
das system auf herz und nieren
überprüfen die haben jetzt ein ganz
langes protokoll dabei an versuchen an
tests die die durchführen müssen
und erst wenn alle tests erfolgreich
gelaufen sind dann fliegen die zur iss
dockten dort an nach 19 stunden werden
sie dort ankommen und werden auf der iss
dann normalen er wissenschaftsbetrieb
dann auch mit unterstützen und wenn sie
wieder zurück fliegen steht auch noch
mal eine verschiedene protokolle an
experimente bei denen diese kapsel
getestet wird und erst wenn alle diese
tests erfolgreich abgeschlossen sind
dann geht es mit dem nächsten flug dann
direkt zur iss zum andocken und dann
auch wieder direkt zurück zur landung
wir gehen mal hier im studio zu
professor werner mit der frage wie
werden denn eigentlich diejenigen
ausgewählt die jetzt beim nächsten oder
übernächsten flug dabei sind wie macht
man das gibt es da würfel oder sagen sie
matthias von meiner seite aus ist ja
sozusagen ich bin ja sozusagen seinen
chef deshalb freue ich mich ihn zu sehen
die auswahl der astronautin astronauten
ist ein sehr komplizierter vorgang also
als matthias maurer mit ausgewählt wurde
da waren 8913 bewerberinnen und bewerber
die mussten alle schon mal vorlegen dass
sie gesund sind und dann gibt es einen
mehrjährigen auswahlprozess bis man dann
2009 die astronautin astronauten
ausgewählt hatte
und matthias kam dann aus dieser gruppe
noch später dazu da ist da wird alles
mögliche getestet also erstmal
gesundheit das ist klar aber eben auch
psychologische stärken die wir immer
sehen und das was ich vorhin schon
gesagt habe dass sie wirklich in der
lage sind diese drei funktionen zu haben
nämlich team verlor und chef
und wenn das alles stimmt und alles
zusammenpasst dann müssen sie noch sich
zusammenfinden in dem europäischen
astronautenkorps und dann müssen sie
natürlich noch ausbildungen durchlaufen
spezielle ausbildung und erstmal ein
basistraining und dann spezielle
ausbildung auch für eine mission ist
also schon anstrengend matthias wir
haben auch gerade jetzt gesprochen
mit reinhold ewald über seine zeit
zwischen verschiedenen städten und
ausbildungs orten wie ist das denn bei
ihnen sind sie alle paar wochen woanders
und trainieren war da und mal dort ja
als astronaut trainiert man
hauptsächlich an den orten an denen auch
die er hat die verschiedenen module
stehen das bedeutet wir in europa wir
sind besitzer des kolumbus moduls auf
der ss und alle astronauten die zur iss
fliegen und das columbus modul dann auch
benutzen wollen die müssen zu uns nach
köln kommen und dort trainieren der
robotische abend der ist ein kanada
gebaut worden die kanadischen kollegen
haben dort die verantwortung also müssen
alle astronauten die den robotischen
armen bedienen wollen nach kanada zum
training
ein großteil der station ist unter
amerikanischer verantwortung und
deswegen ist ein großteil des trainings
auch dann in houston deswegen bin ich
jetzt auch gerade wieder hier um meine
kenntnisse in den verschiedenen systemen
der ss aufzufrischen und auch diesen
weltraumspaziergang wieder zu üben ein
teil der systeme werden aber auch in
japan unterrichtet und dann auch in
russland was sich jetzt geändert hat ist
in der vergangenheit sind wir mit
russischen kapseln zur iss geflogen da
war ja der alexander gerst kurzem auf
der station luca capitano ist in diesem
jahr gerade gelandet und deswegen war
fast die hälfte des trainings in
russland das wird sich nun ändern wenn
wir mit amerikanischen kapseln zur iss
fliegen dann ist eigentlich der großteil
des trainings in den usa weil ich das
war wir bekommen hier gerade die
information vielleicht haben sie die
auch schon in houston bekommen dass es
einen startabbruch gibt und zwar
aufgrund der wetterbedingungen
wir sind jetzt bei 22 25 also ziemlich
genau acht minuten vor dem geplanten
start das ist nicht ungewöhnlich wir
haben ja eben darüber gesprochen wie oft
dieses schon passiert ist
gerade beim space shuttle trotzdem noch
mal an sie die frage wie geht man in
einer solchen situation mit einer
solchen startabbruch lage aus ist das
tiefe enttäuschung oder wie stellen sie
sich das vor
ja also in flotte da muss man glaube ich
damit rechnen
natürlich steckt da enorm viel
anspannung im ganzen team bei den
astronauten auch bei den familien jeder
fiebert auf diesen start hinaus hin und
wenn dann so kurz vor dem start wetter
abgesagt wird dann ist natürlich schon
die enttäuschung groß aber ich denke
alle wissen am samstag oder sonntag gibt
es dann ersatztermine und so dass man in
wenigen tagen hoffentlich dann an der
gleichen stelle ist und dann erfolgreich
durchstarten kann
es ist teil einfach der prozedur man
erstmal ganz herzlichen dank
professor werner startabbruch haben wir
erfahren wetter mal wieder in florida
sie haben eben gesagt ja im grunde ist
das ja nun mal so das ist eine
sicherheitsfrage und das ist völlig klar
ist es eine abwägung oder ist es ein
ganz klares prozedere nach dem mann
tatsächlich sagen kann wir haben ja
normalerweise bis vor dem start jede
einzelne station die gefragt wird unter
anderem das wetter und da heißt es dann
immer go oder no go
in diesem fall ist es beim wetter logo
und das reicht dann auch aus um zu sagen
dass riskieren wir jetzt nicht richtig
ich kenne das natürlich sozusagen aus
verantwortungsbereich als nur von
französisch-guyana
aber da haben wir das auch ganz klar wir
haben bezüglich des wetters dort mehrere
fragen die wir haben gewitter ist so
eine schlechte nachricht das andere ist
wenn der wind landwärts ist das wollen
wir auch nicht so gerne weil vielleicht
trümmerteile als auf sand fallen würden
und da ist richtig ein geologe und das
geht bis unmittelbar vor dem start
es macht keinen sinn dort risiken
einzugehen wegen einer wettersituation
so traurig das ist und man natürlich
nicht nur die astronauten dann auch ich
fiebere natürlich immer auf jeden start
hin auch heute dann ist aber
gleichzeitig habe ich das ich weiß nicht
wie es im rheinland geht da sollte er
noch mal was sagen für mich ist das auch
gleichzeitig das gefühl offensichtlich
verantwortungsvolle entscheidungen und
das beruhigt mich dann auch wieder
aber naja wie siehst du also die
entscheidung über einen start gehört zu
den momenten wo wir astronauten sein das
muss verantwortungsvoll getragen
geschehen man kann nicht weil gerade
fürther juli ist sagen wir müssen wir
waren hoch wir haben alle kameras auf
uns gerichtet und jetzt geht's los also
das ist schon dann eine frage auch die
management wirklich verantwortungsvollen
mit blick aufs risiko getroffen werden
muss die die kuh wird auch vorher immer
natürlich auf dieses risiko hin befragt
also wenn irgendwelche dinge werden im
ablauf des der startvorbereitung falsch
laufen da ist auch die kuh immer
involviert und kriegt das gesagt damit
auch die crew dann letztlich im bilde
ist hier weiß ich nicht wir haben den
sprechfunk er jetzt nicht gehört aber
den beiden war schon klar also den
turmhoch fuhren
das ist heute marginal da wollten solche
gewitterwolken ran und das also
zumindest die die sportfischer da nicht
raus gefahren sind und dann einen staat
zu machen ist natürlich nicht der beste
tag so ist da die ausnahme wirklich weil
nur ja also letztlich haben wir auf
einer interkontinentalrakete gesessen
und die musste starten wenn sich die die
kriegs entscheidung gefallen ist klingt
ein bisschen blöd aber die war sehr viel
robuster schon ausgelegt aber hier haben
wir ja noch zeit in den nächsten tagen
das noch mal zu wiederholen aber auch
die wetterverhältnisse in kasachstan
sind normalerweise stabiler also das
wird schon hart da wird schon mal aber
ist nicht das ist wieder aber ich denke
ganz wichtig dass das ein ganz
kaltblütiger prozess sein muss der sagt
oh oh oh da kann man nicht sagen ach
jetzt ist aber der präsident extra
gekommen und mit seiner gattin
jetzt fliegen wir doch mal lieber oder
mit etwas sieht das darf nicht passieren
das führte unter umständen zu ärger ist
auch bei mir schon passiert wenn wir
dann negative entscheidungen getroffen
haben dann das dann gesagt wird ja weil
sie hätten doch politisch vollkommen
falsche entscheidung es darf nicht
politisch sein hier geht es um
menschenleben
hier geht es um eine technik und die
soll funktionieren
und da gibt es kein abwägen zwischen
politischem willen und den menschen
leben das darf es nicht geben
jetzt muss noch eine geschichte erzählen
das war beim ersten startversuch für die
2 92 93 nach langer langer vorbereitung
und einer endlosen geschichte mit tank
ventilen die immer aufgehen
falsche meldungen waren wir wirklich bis
zu -8 gekommen
und da gibt es dann einen halt das haben
sie hier nicht so dramatisch gemacht
aber im shuttle gab es dann eingebaute
halb punkte und dann wurde weiter
gezählt und weiter waren wir eigentlich
noch nie gekommen und das ganze team in
oberpfaffenhofen was dann später diese
mission wissenschaftlich betreut die
sagte also darf so wie wir das heute
losgehen dann blieb das drei sekunden
vor abheben stehen das ist also ein
moment den man nie vergisst
ich habe ich war live auf kommentar ich
habe etwa 20 sekunden gebraucht um dann
zu sagen
die kuh ist jetzt in sicherheit und der
arm wird wieder eingeschränkt und die
kommen jetzt wieder raus ich habe mich
nachher gewundert wo ich diese art er
nahm aber der arme ist wieder da wir
sehen uns auf den bildern
das heißt die crew hat jetzt neben der
doch sehr feurigen möglichkeit die sich
von der rakete zu retten dann jetzt auch
die möglichkeit sich über diesen coup in
sicherheit zu begeben während der
treibstoff abgepumpt werden jetzt würde
würde man normalerweise ja sagen da
setzt man sich rein und dann möchte man
fliegen und jetzt klappt das doch nicht
das große enttäuschung war
wahrscheinlich ist es tatsächlich ja so
wie sie es beschrieben haben die
astronauten sagen das war ein klares
prozedere und es hieß heim einmal oder
vielleicht sogar mehrfach know how und
das ist einfach und die beiden sind ja
schon geflogen also da ist natürlich
jetzt das berufsqualifizierende ereignis
schon gewesen und damit haben sie
vielleicht jetzt sogar ein bisschen
vorfreude das ganze nochmal einem
schicken auto da gefahren werden und
ist natürlich lässt sich gibt es kostet
auch geld an der an bord der station
brennt nichts an ehrlich gesagt die drei
da oben die sollten wir auch mal
erwähnen der chris cassidy als commander
ist ja mit einer sojus hochgeflogen noch
der letzten die die amerikaner gekauft
haben
anatoliy wann ist ein erfahrener schon
zwei expeditionen geflogen da oben
russischer kollege die man wagner
neuling jetzt aber auch schon seine muss
april bis jetzt also anderthalb monate
hinter sich hat die machen jetzt ruhig
weiter und erwarten dann dass sie die
verstärkung halt in einem oder zwei tage
später bekommen wir haben eben darauf
hingewiesen
man muss das ganz sachlich und seriös
entscheiden
gibt es tatsächlich so ein bisschen weg
müssen uns vorstellen das könnte ja
gewesen sein in florida das gefühl man
möchte den präsidenten mal beweisen und
vor allen dingen in annas möchte das
beweisen das klappt irgendwie die
verantwortlichen sind bretter haft ich
hoffe es ich hoffe es
ich kenne jetzt persönlich der hat
natürlich auch immer die tendenz
wirklich was zeigen zu wollen
aber ich gehe davon aus dass er das
nicht persönlich entscheidet sondern da
sind ist eine mannschaft die wägt ab ist
dieses wetter für uns zu risikoreich
oder nicht und es muss eine harte klare
entscheidung werden und dann muss man
sich auch beugen da darf es kein wenn
und aber geben oder so auch wolle man es
nicht doch versuchen das geht einfach
nicht wir reden hier von menschenleben
und diese beiden astronauten sind nicht
eingestiegen um ihr leben zu riskieren
die sind eingestiegen um einen
erfolgreichen flug zu machen natürlich
haben sie das risiko bekannt aber nicht
das risiko es kann sein die unten auf
der erde sagen wir fliegen jetzt mal es
ist nicht so schlimm dass da dieses
risiko will kein astronaut nehmen
sondern die sagen wir gehen dafür aus
die verantwortlichen entscheiden auf der
basis der information und deshalb ist es
gut ist es auch beruhigend so eine
entscheidung zu sehen da muss man jetzt
noch sagen warum macht man jetzt nicht
die stunde bis es vielleicht auf klagt
nun das ist hat zu tun damit dass wir
ein objekt anfliegen wollen was schon
eine welt alle ist das fliegt auf
treffen quasi immer muss zu einer
bestimmten zeit starten um überhaupt den
treibstoff zu haben dieses objekt was ja
schon sich in 400 kilometer höhe auf
einer bestimmten bahn bewegt die
raumstation eben zu erreichen und da hat
man nicht den luxus auch bei der falcon
9 nicht den luxus dass man da beliebig
hinterherhecheln kann vor allen dingen
versucht die sogenannte ein das ist ein
wichtiger parameter die inflation zu
drehen das heißt der winkel den die
bahnebene mit dem äquator bildet wenn
man die versucht noch günstig zu
erreichen dann wird sehr in treibstoff
intensiv und deshalb startet man genau
in dem moment wo die bahnebene die dreht
sich auch noch einmal pro tag durch die
erde durch sozusagen die bahnebene mit
dem start doch zusammen ist da hat man
dann mal ein paar minuten vielleicht bei
fahren können weil er so sagt man ein
paar sekunden
aber da muss man das start passieren sie
sind physiker und sagen uns deswegen ist
es so dass am samstag um 21 uhr 22
genauer gesagt wird und dann muss das
auch klappen kommt immer früher dann der
startpunkt aber nur einmal pro tag
sozusagen
und damit war es das jetzt für heute bin
jetzt in den technischen feinheiten
nicht drin warum man drei tage
turnaround also wieder befüllen und
sowas hat aber das ist das ist für jede
rakete anders matthias maurer was kommt
auf sie in den nächsten tagen zu an
training sehr gut morgen erst einmal in
den pool springen und dann geht es
weiter mit den verschiedenen systemen
also heute bevor ich jetzt hier zur
sendung gekommen bin hatte ich
verschiedene trainingseinheiten 1 war
wie benutze ich die toilette auf der iss
und da gibt es auch gute nachrichten es
wird bald in zukunft noch eine neue
toilette geben weil die besatzung auf
der ice ist ja auch anwachsen wird
deswegen brauchen wir neben der jetzt
vorhandenen toilette in dem
amerikanischen teil und der anderen
toilette im russischen teil kommt noch
eine dritte toilette dazu und die muss
man auch warten können
dann hatte ich einen training wie fange
ich eine versorgungs kapsel ein alle
güter die hoch gebracht werden auch die
die der nachschub für uns also essen
experimente kleidung kommt der mit
versorgungs kapseln und die meisten
versorgungs kapseln können nicht
automatisch andocken und deswegen müssen
wir lernen wie wir diese kapseln mit dem
robotischen armen sozusagen aus dem
weltraum fischen wenn sie in der nähe
der iss sind diese tragen mit der die
amerikanischen kollegen heute zur
station staaten wollen oder wollten ist
gleichzeitig auch als frachter nutzbar
und bis vor kurzem mussten wir diesen
frachter anfang mit dem robotischen aber
in zukunft wird mit dieser modernen
variante dann das automatische doggen
möglich sein das heißt wir müssen dann
nur noch einen amerikanischen frachter
und den japanischen frachter einfangen
können und ja dort darüber hinaus gibt
es auch noch andere systeme die wir
immer wieder üben und auf löschen müssen
sie sind bitte beneidenswert sie hören
dass hier an und sagt meine güte würde
ich auch gerne im augenblick machen so
habe ich zumindest den eindruck oder das
löst man sich wahrscheinlich nie so ganz
von ja dann wünschen wir ihnen
ja sie sagen sie springen in den pool
das wird sich ein bisschen leichter und
werber gesprochen worüber sie da
arbeiten müssen und wie anstrengend das
ist also springe sie in den pool
viel spaß dabei in anführungsstrichen
herzlichen dank matthias maurer aus
houston live zugeschaltet bei uns
professor werner wir haben jetzt einen
startabbruch wir haben jetzt eine ein
normales prozedere muss man dazu sagen
das ist nichts ungewöhnliches nach dem
was wir besprochen haben ist das jetzt
für einen masken sagen wir mal
image-verlust nein man das nein auf gar
keinen fall
also man muss auch wissen erst mal es
ist jetzt nicht wie beim auto ist stellt
den motor ab und gehe nach hause also so
funktioniert das auch nicht reinhard
evers hat darauf hingewiesen dass muss
jetzt sorgfältig wieder entleert werden
die ganzen systeme müssen runter
gefahren werden die müssen auch alle
noch mal überprüft werden für den
nächsten start
nein ich denke es zeigt im gegenteil es
ist für spacex glaube ich ein beweis der
seriosität jedenfalls aus meiner sicht
das jetzt nicht auf gut glück so sehr
einfach gestartet wird sondern dass auch
space exakt wie hier reden wir über
menschen hier werden wir die höchsten
vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen die möglich
sind
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob nasa entschieden
hat oder space ex entschieden hat das
entzieht sich meiner kenntnis aber ich
glaube es ist überhaupt kein image
verlust und dass der präsident jetzt in
florida ist
das war nicht so wichtig für den staat
wird wahrscheinlich in kleinen bogen
fliegen und dann auf seinem golfplatz
bitte dass die person schlechten wetter
überhaupt anfliegen konnte dass es ist
so dass das die wettervorhersage oder
die die wetterbedingungen tatsächlich
auch noch von amerikanischen
streitkräfte einhalten also dem
wetterdienst meteo logischen dienst der
amerikanischen streitkräfte geliefert
wird und dann entscheidet ein lounge
direktor der meines wissens spacex
angehört also das team in der feier teil
in dem in dem launch center und auch in
hoffen was ja älter ist ist basics aber
mit verbindungs menschen die die nasa
dieses nasa interface haben aber die
tatsache dass und das war ja bei dem
spaceshuttle auch schon so dass die
meteorologie von der armee gemacht wird
das heißt also eine militärische
komponente hat nicht militärisch im
sinne von kriegerisch sondern
militärisch im sinne von unabhängig ist
wahrscheinlich ja auch eine ganz
wichtige funktion
und sie haben wahrscheinlich leserbilder
ausgewertet unserer sehr schönen
erdbeobachtungssatellit mit ihnen
natürlich in bester auflösung und freie
datenverteilung ihn zur verfügung stehen
und uns nicht wie wir wissen da gibt es
nicht ganz so einer genauigkeit aber das
ist ja auch im militärischen sinne der
amerikaner gedacht wir wollen gleich mal
in einer dokumentation noch mal schauen
auf die bedeutung des mondes wir haben
jetzt ganz viel über spaceshuttle
gesprochen und die entscheidung space
shuttle war ja auch eine entscheidung
dafür in die erdumlaufbahn zu gehen und
nicht etwa zum mond zurückzukehren
da gibt es aber eine ganze reihe von
plänen zwischen ja also ich bin da sehr
froh dass der mond endlich wieder
entdeckt wurde der mond wurde ja
verlassen von apollo 17 zum letzten mal
mit menschen danach gab es eine reihe
von robotischen missionen der mond birgt
immer noch eine reihe von geheimnissen
es wurde als ich 2007 zum deutschen
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt kam und
gesagt hat lasst uns doch zum mond
fliegen wurde mir gesagt wörner
das ist unsinn das ist ein toter stein
da fliegt man nicht hin
mittlerweile wissen dass wissen wir dass
dieser stein mitnichten totes wir wissen
das wasser auf dem mond ist wir wissen
dass einige ressourcen da sind und ich
sage immer wir wollen nicht back to the
moon zurück zum mond sondern vorwärts
zum mond was ich damit sagen will ist
nicht wie apollo kurz hinfliegen
aussteigen flagge hessen ein paar
fußabdrücke hinterlassen wieder
einsteigen und zurück fliegen ich weiß
ja mehr gemacht aber ich mache jetzt mal
ein bisschen übertrieben sondern wenn
das nächste mal zum mond geflogen wird
dann hoffe ich erstens dass das
international gesteht wir werden erleben
dass die amerikaner etwas schneller
national fliegen aber insgesamt hoffe
ich dass international geflogen wird
dass die wissenschaft sehr stark im
vordergrund steht und dass wir nicht
alles material von der erde mitbringen
sondern dass wir mond material benutzen
um zb ein observatorium auf dem mond
rückseite aufzubauen um tief ins weltall
zu gucken
im schatten des mondes sozusagen und
deshalb habe ich ja auch diesen begriff
des mondes geprägt weil ich glaube wir
sollten zum mond und das gemeinsam mit
den internationalen freunden und das
bedeutet aber auch wir brauchen eine
noch sehr viel größere sicherheit wenn
wir dahin fliegen
es gibt ja nun ernst zu nehmende
experten die sagen damals standort fifty
fifty bei apollo 11
ja es ist an fifty fifty man wenn man
das rückwirkend liegt anguckt ist eben
sonst gar nicht wissen wie man es gar
nicht wissen also zum beispiel während
apollo 11 zum start ging wurde apollo 12
vorbereitet für den fall dass apollo 11
schief geht also das würden wir heute
niemals machen wir würden sagen wenn das
schiefgeht machen wir erstmal eine pause
und gucken von trans lag aber dieser
racing space der wettlauf im all war so
massiv dass man unbedingt das erreichen
wollte man hat es erreicht aber zum
beispiel die die astronauten hatten
großes glück dass kein starker
sonnenwind aufgetreten ist während ihrer
flüge
aller flüge denn so ein sonnen wind
könnte sowohl die elektronik heftig in
mitleidenschaft ziehen aber auch die
astronauten werden kann entsprechend der
schutz da ist und das würde man
sicherlich und wird man nicht wenn man
jetzt wieder neu den mond im blickpunkt
nimmt er akzeptieren also das ist eine
andere geschichte heute und wenn wir
dann noch zum mars reden dann reden wir
über noch ganz andere dimensionen
in der nächsten sendung rüber zum hüllen
mediation das ist das erste was wir am
montag suchen werden deckung vor diesen
schalen ereignissen tatsächlich hat das
zwischen apollo 16 nach platz 17 ein
ausbruch der sonne gegeben der die als
eventueller astronauten wieder unterwegs
gewesen werden aufs höchste gefährdet
hat dass der mond bietet nicht den
komfort einer einer magnetischen
abschirmung in einer atmosphäre
professor werner ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie bei mir waren
wir sind am samstag um 21 und 22 wieder
live und schauen auf den start der dann
hoffentlich funktionieren wird 21/22
live bei uns bei phoenix und das was wir
jetzt sehen ist das was wir gerade
besprochen haben nämlich die rückkehr
zum mond die erben apollo apollos sind
auf dem weg wieder zum mond